talk to me a little bit about what that
is what pots means pots is actually a
description of the body's response there
might even be several mechanisms behind
the manifestations of pots but we
measure pots by measuring an increase in
the patient's heart rate from going from
lying down to sitting up or sitting up
to standing in adults if your heart rate
jumps a little when you stand that's
normal but in pots it will jump 30 beats
per minute or more so you go from 90
which feels like a normal walking around
heart rate to to 120 in a couple minutes
and that feels very uncomfortable in the
moment so people who have experienced it
know it's not something you would not
notice this is
NSU prepare to dominate